نفتح حلقتنا بهذا الخبر والانجاز التاريخي
في ليله لن ينساها محبو الردس قالوا انه
اسوا مواسمه مع ليفربول وان ارقامه لم تعد
كالسابق لكن الواقع يحكي قصه اخرى صلاح
يصبح الهداف التاريخي لليفربول في مباريات
الدوري الانجليزي بعدما وصل لهدفه رقم 129
في البطوله وخلال وخمس مباراه خاضها بقميص
الريتس منذ انضمامه في 2017 احرز صلاح
هدفين وصنع مثلهما في اكتساح لفريق غريمه
مانشستر يونايتد بنتيجه سبعه مقابل لا شيء
ضمن مباريات في الجوله السادسه والعشرين
من بطوله الدوري وبالانجاز غير المسبوق
تفوق صلاح على اسطوره الفريق المعتذر روبي
باولر يتصدر قائمه هدف في الفريق في
الدوري جنبا الى جنب مع قائمه هدفي الفريق
في دوري ابطال اوروبا الذي يتربى على
عرشها في فبراير الماضي